alright so we have 7 minutes and 15
seconds left on the clock for the
Cleveland Browns
we have weighed in me and Miller Miller
and I and Connor are all going Sam darn
'old Sims over there is going Josh Allen
I'm just look how much do you think his
tweets affect him I don't I don't think
it will
that's a good question what do you what
are your guys takes on that I'll give
you my tank well I I ever not
necessarily read them I just look at it
and go I mean either Donald Baker may
feel they are Josh Rosen's agent have
had these for a long long time Darla in
the same agent okay so it wasn't I think
it's interesting other quarterbacks and
not teams I think it's just some troll
on Twitter these tweets were deleted by
his marketing people by his agents in
January they held them until yesterday
to try to damage him which the army
Tunsil yes
but I mean it's just he's a dumb I think
you don't know the other quarterbacks
agents I just think he was a dumb kid
man I'm so glad Twitter didn't exist
when I was 15 man I'll just say this uh
they're the whole thing like the the D
Vinge D vincenzo kid for Villanova
has the game of his life and afterwards
he's asking questions from Twitter about
his Twitter account and for me it's it's
crazy that that's the story that it was
all day today you know he's calling
Stephen a Smith at 2:00 in the morning
having to answer that on one of the
biggest days of his life I think it's
crazy but also its tweets and if an NFL
team is gonna change their course of
their future because of a tweet when a
kid was 14 years old that tells you
about that franchise more than it tells
you about Josh yeah but I'm looking at
this Browns roster and I'm seeing
weapons all over the place on offense I
have miles Garrett on defense I have
damarious Randall who they just traded
it for some good weapons and Cristian
Kirk see how far away is this Browns
team from from getting to the playoffs
what do you think it depends on who they
drafted quarterback really and I will
know it's let me back up until they fire
Hugh Jackson there far away from the
playoffs dude's won one game in two
years that's in that that's almost
impossible to do hmm I think my question
for Hugh is how is he gonna keep the
locker room motivated the culture is
gonna change a little that's why they
got Tyrod Taylor that's why they gave
Jarvis Landry too much money
yeah they got Todd Haley in there to run
the offense now
you have to overpay to get guys and
clear yeah well yeah they're right there
they got it they know yeah Jarvis
lenders like damn you're gonna send me
to Cleveland what okay buddy better
begin with the area strand we got trader
polar I'm pretty sure he texts me was
like I'm about to get paid so right yeah
but they do they're close they got a lot
of the essentials they're big up front
on both sides of the football
they got decent coordinators on both
sides of Haley and Williams you know
yeah I look at them and I go what are
their biggest needs I don't look at
anything on the offensive line
I really don't look at anything on
offense in general is being desperate
right what are we talking about maybe
corners corners are the biggest night
corners in safety but are they gonna
bill peppers is not the guy we'll see if
the move too strong safety helps they're
gonna get him in the box more you guys
anyone to watch last year knows that
neither of us liked him yeah I thought
he was very overrated
I think you'd still play running back
instead of safety but I think the
Randall playing free safety will be very
good you saw give him a four picks last
year for Green Bay which I running to be
a Pro Bowl player before he got hurt
yeah I don't think they're as far away
is one win in two seasons would indicate
but right I think Hugh Jackson's
especially when you look at the deem the
Browns were seventh against the run last
year in defense they were in a lot of
those games it was an Owen 16 teen that
almost upset a lot of teams and it was
always that the Shawn Kaiser fumble in
the fourth or an interception for Corey
Coleman drop in a wide-open pass yeah
that was horrible I would have cut him
right there
oh man not really no I know you would
first-round pick in a copy of the rope
your Owen 15 your fields on the phone
Baker Mayfield along that you I want to
keep the hair I still have I hope you
just say let me just say this right now
okay can I say it because we're on the
cloud it okay it you don't make fun of
the homeless people because don't worry
if Cleveland takes Baker may feel that
one I'm gonna make fun of it
don't you worry Johnny what I thought I
was getting mad I was at x1 215 484 no
vertical number one pick next to Lake
Erie and he's been playing in the flag
football conference in the big 12 that
will be
bad first pick it's not gonna be like me
an F grade for me because they're still
getting the quarterback they won so I'm
not gonna totally kill it but you got a
I'm gonna have to see it I just got a
text its Baker really I swear to God
yeah I gosh and Baker was on the phone
there's three minutes left and they're
not calling him to ask him what his
favorite you know flowers are so that
means so that means number one none of
us was correct genes I could be
corrected number bold predict me this
person could be lying to me cuz that
stuff does happen and everybody watching
can see this life damn is it's taking a
long Connor has seen me lied to if it's
Baker what are the grades and I cannot
wait to hear Sims is great on I'm not
gonna murder the grade total because
it's at least a quarterback that they
like right and they're picking him so
I'm not gonna and I don't think this
kids a first-round quarterback this
isn't like Blake bortles at three where
I was like no this is like the 70th best
player in the draft pick is in I'm back
at I cannot wait what's your grading my
grade is going to be if it's Baker it's
gonna be like a b-minus
Brown's just text me as Baker yep I just
got one too I got a text too it's Baker
sorry what's your grade
I'll give it a see that Steve's my
fourth quarter egg Wow let's go I'm not
gonna lie
he was my third quarterback I went to my
notes last night and I've read
everything back again cuz I knew we had
the draft today thank you for my my
notes read that he was the fifth
quarterback it was you when you when you
went yeah when you went back and we did
it on the podcast you came away and all
of your notes were he's not that
athletic I need you to read my notes cuz
you make logic of my brain time at times
but this year they say like I like Baker
Mayfield I do too like I'm so I'm very
happy for him a kid that was so
overlooked wait wait this is the problem
this is the problem with you yeah like
we're I know you we like him yeah but
okay if you're gonna take Baker Mayfield
take him at four and takes a qualm
Berkeley one that's what I I think the
change my grade from the B - to the see
- because at that point right there is
Connor
C - C - alright so let me explain to
everybody what we're going to do yeah go
ahead of the draft because we have a
bunch of people getting text that this
is words move it so this what we're
gonna do
we are going to make a br video that
you'll see popping up in the BR app
really in the next time I'd say let's
say see regular meaning as well I'm
gonna go to Miller Miller's gonna talk
about the value was it a smart to take
this player at that position Sims we'll
talk about him fitting into the system
then we're gonna get their grades Roger
Goodell Xin the podium we're beating
them to it let's get this video rolling
Baker may feel the pick at one with the
first pick in the NFL Draft the
Cleveland Browns it was a rumor all day
but I can't believe it's fact Baker
Mayfield is the now the future of the
Cleveland Browns I want to know for your
big board is this work he was the top
player but no definitely not the top
player he was the number four
quarterback on my big board I like Baker
I love the story overcoming the odds of
being a walk-on at Texas Tech a walk-on
at Oklahoma a day 3 projection from NFL
scouts last summer and now he's the
number one pick in the draft it's a
great story he's a playmaker I think he
can come in and play pretty quickly as
long as he can get down Hugh Jackson's
verbage what I mean kudos to him man for
completely changing the story of I am
his prospect Heisman Trophy winner had a
great season John Dorsey said they want
accuracy they want a quarterback who can
handle the cold and they wanted a
confident quarterback who believes he
can come in and change the fate of the
Cleveland Browns Baker Mayfield thinks
he can do it Simms
give me the truth all right the truth is
listen this guy's a first-round
quarterback there's no doubt about that
it's a natural throwing motion he throws
Spyros he can throw with power he can
push the ball down the field and he does
have good pocket presence but at the end
of the day he's 6 1 to 15 he ran for 84
he's got nine and a quarter hands and a
29 inch vertical that just just does not
scream number one pick in the draft to
me let alone coming from the big 12
where we're not talking about any good
defensive players
he was unclearly the best team in the
big 12 I have issues with this just
because it's the number one pick and I I
like Baker Mayfield you know I did all
college season but I didn't think we're
gonna ever be talking about it at the
number one pick this is wrong to me and
this is why it's even more wrong because
just wait till number four to take maker
Mayfield and takes a qualm Berkeley at
once the best argument takes it wanna
take the best player in the draft and I
don't see the difference between Baker
Josh Rose and Josh Alan Rosen Marcel
Alan all gonna be there at 4:00 now I I
would say this no matter whom the Browns
drafted it's an uphill climb to be the
quarterback in Cleveland it is because
20 years you guys haven't got it right
right yeah but I would have gone saying
that's the confidence to get over it and
Todd Haley offensive coordinator maybe
they're gonna run that spread that's
complicated you're great what's your
grade for this I have to give it a seat
because all my board
he was then number four quarterback in
this draft so I'm happy for Baker I hope
it works because Cleveland deserves it
but it's to see ya I'm right there with
you I'm going to see as well I mean yes
do I like Baker Mayfield
I certainly do he's a first round
quarterback but he's not the number one
pick in the draft and I think you could
have got him at four and taken say pops
a qualm barkley 1 so that's my point he
proved a lot of people wrong walking on
and he became the only player in FBS
history with more than 13,500 passing
yards and 1,000 rushing yards apparently
he's gonna have to prove people wrong
again Baker Mayfield the future of the
Cleveland Browns he is he also said a
big 12 record with a touchdown pass in
40 straight games but I feel like a
little shocked up I just lost so much
money betting on Sam Dorn oh man I
forgot my feelings Sam Dorma member
seriously looking at like are you
kidding me like Baker Mayfield is going
up there before me I mean listen I love
Baker Mayfield
I almost feel personally attached to him
because when I got into the media
business after I got done with New
England I went and worked for Fox Sports
and I had to do big 12 football games
and he was on Texas Tech and I'm on TV
going man what does Kliff Kingsbury
doing this is the guy you worth you
thought he had some rustle well I did
yes yeah I get that
- he's not as athletic as Russell Wilson
I was trying to wrap the season when I
was doing college football Notre Dame's
who say like no this guy's definitely a
first rounder but I didn't want to talk
him to the number one pick the Giants
are taking sacrum Barkley no shocker
okay pick us in we're boldly and say we
would have hit sake what's yes it's an a
by the way in the fabulous of a
Plus so Giants just kind of ran up there
so it apparently didn't matter which
quarterback went off the board to the
Jets maybe no it's gonna be frozen
I'll Sade Arnold you think it's not no I
think it's Darden I have been told that
if darn 'old is there it's still gonna
be Rosen this was the shocking thing to
me I did not expect to hear that but I
heard that from somebody pretty damn
smart
all right so say Kwan I mean I'm just
gonna be honest as an Eagles fan
I am afraid playing a giant or something
already
Noel Beckham I mean your say Kwan
Barkley Evan Engram sterling Shepherd
Nate solder hey I'll tell you what man
you've said this all along they can make
a run at a possible Super Bowl that
defense was good two years ago it's all
part last year because their head coach
I can't say that word on camera their
head coach there was no accountability
Connor
make the announcement make it official
listen with the second overall pick the
New York Giants selected running back
say qualm Barclay game is losing his boy
get the two most explosive people in
offense on the same damn team let's do
it bagels are screwed do you mean the
Super Bowl champion close the yearbook
yeah look at the athletes on the Giants
with the second pick in the draft the
New York Giants Alexei Kwan Barclay
Berna with Odell Beckham so now old baby
Eli has weapons this was your top player
so at number two it's a steal
bro this is my top player this is a
tougher running back I've ever graded he
has the highest grade I've ever given
someone not named Andrew Luck or Von
Miller wow this dude is special on and
off the field 233 pounds for four speed
catches the ball like a receiver scored
on kick returns punt returns
he's like boobie miles just put them on
the field and let him do something fake
one was the best player in the draft I'm
glad the Giants didn't overthink it yes
say Kuantan is the most explosive player
I've seen come out in the draft since
I've been in this business I'll say that
right right off the bat he's one of the
greatest running backs I've ever watched
coming out of college he's in that
conversation with Adrian Peters and when
he came out alcohol
yeah it's not the same style I get that
but the guy is an absolute freak of
nature and all aspects and I really
think he's gonna even be better in the
pros because Penn State only had one run
play and they didn't even know how to
utilize him in the pass game okay
so he's gonna go to Pat Shermer and he's
gonna have 9 million different ways to
get him the bata the backfield you think
Alvin Kamara was tough to the family oh
my god have fun with sake one bar watch
the Wisconsin tape three of their
linebackers keyed on say Quon so tres
McSorely could walk into the end zone
that's of no one respected the pass game
right everyone keyed on say grade four
shake on it this is an a this is the I
love this pick and I've been ton our
listeners on six football since February
this was going to be the pick we love
this kid
I think the Giants got it right an A
plus plus plus plus plus plus plus
you're in trouble in Philadelphia big
guy big lose coming yeah he's the man
I'm getting an a-plus yeah I will say
this he is also out of all the prospects
not only the most athletic yeah only the
most well-read but I also say this he's
a good kid in every NF handsome he's
handsome Berkeley they got troubles with
Odell is he the new face of the New York
Giants second pick for big blue
we need to cut the Roger Bacon out
say Quan Berkeley how good can the
Giants be next year with this guy
anywhere 50 catches lash I think he's a
sixteen hundred yard player as a rookie
I really do I I think he's better than
Zeke because he is I think he has a
little better open field speed yeah and
and you also don't have to worry about
any of the all-filipino distractions
with this kid when he declared I
remember talking to him I was like what
he been doing he's like I've been
talking to all these NFL running back
trying to figure out how to get my body
right because I've been training for the
combine now I'm trying to figure how to
train to be an NFL player he was doing
that in January right February so I
think he's a special guy in terms of not
just the athletic ability but the mental
aspect what is it show predictions for
the New York and Arnold Rosen I don't
trust him with the Jets he seems to
always know so he might already know
that but I'm gonna roses Sims is going
Rosen Miller's going darn 'old left I'm
gonna steal Simpsons Thunder here I'm
gonna go with Rosen - I just want Rosen
in New York so it's Sims love cover
stick to football here yes and what do
you go with Connor I'm going with Samms
Arnold you're on Sam Donald I think
they'll love the floor of this player I
think he will be unfazed by New York and
I think he fits in with the culture
let's face it they've spent three years
building this culture and you look at
Sam's early talk to anyone that
interviewed him at the NFL Combine they
said it was far away not the best
quarterback interview the best player
yeah great these matters
you're right Connor know he was great I
mean we had him in here earlier in this
week I was blown away by the guy I'm
gonna be rooting for back yeah I get it
I only think I pushed back with Sam dorm
lose this you guys have heard me said I
just the safest pick in the draft thing
bothers me I mean for a guy that's young
and coming from a raw offense and
doesn't isn't great with in the pocket
he's got great feet but he doesn't have
great feel yet he has a little bit of a
flawed motion and led college football
turnovers that does not say safest pick
that's my biggest thing she does have to
clean up some of that one mechanic guy
he drops the ball solo right and that's
where a lot of his fumbles happen
because he does have smaller hands yes
24 starts 21 fumbles for say I'm darling
Marcus Mariota had a fumbling problem at
Oregon as well and he has it in the NFL
I think fumbles can be fixed sure I'm
more worried about like I mean the
interceptions are more of a concern for
me cuz I think he tried to play hero
at times my comparison for him was Tony
Romo because when it's great and he's in
rhythm he's gonna beat you so many
different ways and he could play outside
the pocket but if he's not on let me
know it's gonna be a 3 pikmin let me the
way I think this is taking long this is
something I heard and I heard this
before I walked in their room
and I is Sam Darnell but the Broncos I
heard it just as I was walking in here I
had a friend text me that goes you know
I think Elway's been laying in the weeds
about Sam Darnell and that they might
make a move if he's on the board so you
think that it's a friend I trust he told
me he was like you know treat I'm still
saying Sam rose but I think the reason
it's taking so long because I think
people right now are going damn sand
Arnold's there at 3:00 maybe we make a
move sir and I'm just going maybe it's
the Broncos Donald's on the phone
Donald's on the phone picks in so
they're gonna go darling I get so Rosen
I don't want to overplay the hand of
things that we've heard but I had heard
that Darnell was the number one player
on their board yeah I told you I thought
Donald was the pick yesterday and then
today I was told so I guess I'm gonna be
wrong here pick is in Darnell let's go
to the counter Corner Jets took a
quarterback from the pac-12 and it's Sam
Donald so the current scoreboard is I
don't remember but we all missed on the
first one so you're up two to one
I mean I'm competitive so I'm keeping
score in my head oh you have it okay so
Sam Darnell's so what do you think
happened mister so that means you're
bold predictions for all of your ball
predictions Ron what's wrong that means
that I'm the only one that could get the
bold prediction here's the real
interesting thing though is just yet
where it's Rosen gonna end up now that's
this is gonna be the new storyline of
the draft who's first Sam dartle go to
the a plus like the balls to trade up
from six to three a month ago and say
you know what we're gonna get our guy
like that that is such a just a hero
move of we're gonna get our guy and Mike
McKagan give me some lotto numbers
brokers Leonard Williams false huge
Jamal Adams Falls to you now Sam Donald
Falls to you dare say hey - I don't know
how he does it yeah I'm excited for this
because Sims has not been a huge Sam
Donald fan I just have questions I got
questions about he's definitely a top 20
pick I've said that from the city work
you like his athleticism with Jeremy
Bates as often I
yes he's going to fit this the soul set
they wanted this off you can move
outside the pocket a little bit right
let's make this video save the good
stuff for the video bow I'm so happy for
Connor are you are you happy oh yeah I
mean I liked Josh Rosen better but I get
the pic I explain to you guys on the so
he's not Mark Sanchez he's not marked
this guy is today it's the Jets who have
burnt burned out on quarterbacks right
this is the public media safe pic and I
think that's a little bit that just I
just throw in that angle I think that's
a good angle let's put it in the video
we knew when the Jets traded up they
were trying to get a quarterback at
three but four weeks we wondered were
they going to be stuck with the
leftovers of Cleveland and New York and
apparently they get the number one guy
on their board at 3 Miller the value
he'll they give the number one
quarterback on my board in Sam Darnell
just 20 years old coming out of USC
amazing ability to I think see the field
and his upside is tremendous you talk to
you in the NFL they love the kid he's
committed to football he has accuracy
you can improve some of the touch and
timing but he was a playmaker for the
Trojans he's tough plays linebacker in
high school he's clutch tore apart our
Texas Longhorns lit the game where Texas
was leading and they said hey Sam going
that's the ballgame buddy and he kept
doing it so I think he was the best
quarterback in the draft I think he also
has upside that a lot of people don't
realize because they think oh you came
out of USC you're your pro ready I don't
like T Martin's offense at all I think
it's gonna be a great fit in Jeremy
Bates scheme yeah what do you think
about him as the Jets future the Jets
future listen that the future is bright
for this kid he's got everything you
want as a franchise starting quarterback
was he my favorite quarterback in this
draft certainly not no do I have
questions about him yes I do but there's
there's no denying his ability to make
plays off schedule his ability to make
some different kind of throws when he's
in similar positions Hocking he does not
he certainly does not there's things you
should clean up in his game yes and he's
not an elite level athlete and I could
say out of all the quarterbacks drafted
there wasn't one thing I could look at
and go he was the best
but at the end of the day I get it he
was the definite top 20 pick he could
the French shot turnaround the franchise
he is a little bit more of a project
than people I think have realized but
him with Jeremy Bates Jeremy Bates
offense was very exciting in Denver when
he had Jay Cutler now I know I'm not
trying to save Jake but this is the kind
of skill set this guy has to make this
all I paid for this I gave it an A+ I
think just simple what does he do well
what is he great at everything I heard
was his interviews and board work were
off the charts good one person told me
it was up there with golf and went in
terms of just how well it prepared he
was right his football IQ I think it's a
great pick for the Jets and I loved it
when they made this trade or after the
combine or Rebecca Marsh everybody was
like how can you trade up already you
gave up too much to move up three spots
they just got the top player on their
board yeah I'm gonna give it a - again
he's not my favorite quarterback here I
certainly I like Josh Rosen but I can't
get mad at the Jets at all for getting a
guy that they got at the top of their
board and they obviously feel confident
this is the guy for the future I'll tell
you what he also has it in his blood
lines we love talking about his
grandfather hammer yes an Olympian and
was the Marlboro Man well guess what
Sam dartle is now the face of a football
team in New York City he's got to get
those acting chops ready because Sam
dartle is about to be big-time Jets
future is in his hands and I've got
little hands and he's gonna fumble it
I'm so sad my parents didn't name me
dick hammer incredible man well you
might not have the tools quarterback for
the Jets means the Jets go the AFC
championship in the next two years I'm
not gonna say that quite yet I think
that this is a thing where Sam Donald
this is where I think people are he
needs a year or two to sit behind
somebody you have McCallum they have an
account exactly right this is a good
situation for him so the new counsel I
think McCann is a very underrated
teacher oh it's perfect guy great guy
and the counts also a lot more athletic
than people think I mean not at this
point I've seen that dude play
basketball what I'm saying since watched
it in person yes all right
Browns are back on the classroom can we
all just say it's Bradley chub should be
I mean it should be yes lock I mean I
don't know they took me they took
we may feel the one I don't know what
the hell they're all right so Bradley
chub is the bet for all of my unit think
what is that duo of Bradley chub and
Miles Garrett arey yeah what is it
better duo my only question would be
this is I see when I look at the Browns
I see a lot of holes in the middle of
the D line cuz they were like the worst
run defense the NFL their secondaries a
mess but you talked about waiting the
patience of Jabril you don't draft a
corner here miles Garrett and Bradley
Chubb they're gonna have a lot of rookie
contracts for like the next 3-4 years
are we up there with the Chargers are we
up there well I think they're different
than the charges because the the size of
these guys yeah it's just different yeah
and and we're also talking about freak
athletes here and I think with miles
Garrett let's not forget a year ago we
were all gushing about this kid about
how great he was and I think with Chubb
he's a Joey Bosa level player where he
can play weak side and just let him go
because he has agility he has power he
can shed blocks that he does have enough
Bend I love him I I don't know why he
didn't get talked about a little bit
more in this class right I think maybe
just because the quarterbacks were all
going so early
yeah we talked about say Kwan and then
everybody turned on say Quan star you're
right they just got the bronze man and
they could they could shock us all I'll
say this it's it's shocking that Baker
went first but if you would have told me
that the first three picks were Sam darn
'old say Quan Baker Mayfield yeah that's
not right so we're kind of where we
thought we might be a but this could be
a trade scenario two we talked about in
the pre-show about trades teams trying
to come up this is where you do it if
you're trying to come up do they value
they go me and we can get some really
good corners if we drop down to 12 or
wherever it may be so this is gonna be
interesting picks in here we go alright
so I I feel very confident but not a
trade Bradley Chubb okay it's a trade no
that's not a tree do you know who it is
I guess I'll let you guys go I'm going
to yeah I'm going job to I would have as
well but it's Denzel Ward wow they're
gonna go denzel's we're going to say
that we had this whole system where
Connor was gonna run I'm just saying
typical stick to football man
Sims is gonna be pissed too the second
yeah what is your prediction for Sims is
great Sims is going to give this a C+
because he's going to say
Denzel Ward can you know mirror and
match and has a lead athleticism but
he's not gonna make enough plays on the
ball and at number four he would have
taken Bradley to shove the pair of Miles
Garrett for an instant top three pass
rush to put it on the video I don't want
to work this we're done
forget all right what's your grades I'm
gonna give it a b-plus Sims be real here
man
man it was theirs never mind I know it
what it is about their boards i know i
yeah i I'm going to give this a c-minus
Wow yeah so now I'm thinking this now
I'm thinking I know that Shane ray is on
Denver but his contracts coming up after
this season what is dental and Miller
Bradshaw Indianapolis is salivating and
member there was a lot of stories that
came out this week that the Raiders
wanted to move up to get Bradley Chubb
and I know that I'm sure Elway wants to
trade back it might be your former coach
Jon Gruden trying to go up and get baby
it would be that would be amazing to to
see Chavan mackovic oh yeah oh man would
pass up Shelby Mac it's good or Mack
jump Wow Denzil Wow
so I'm gonna tell you what not in my
wildest dreams that I think the Browns
were gonna leave this trapped with Baker
Mayfield and Denzel Ward they're like
short guys waiting for them to dry at 33
if you like short guys let's do this
video Browns taking Denzel Ward now look
we're talking crap he's a first team ap
all-american but let's do a video
if you thought you knew what the Browns
were doing for this draft you were
absolutely wrong because they went out
there to Baker Mayfield at 1:00 and
Denzel word cornerback from Ohio State
at 4:00 I need the value did you expect
him to go this high I thought that he
could go with the next pick at actually
number 5 overall so the value is there I
had him ranked number 9 overall as the
top corner in this class compared him to
Chris Harris jr. he's a little bit
undersized for an outside corner was
just a one-year starter because of
Marshawn Lattimore and Gary and Conley
but you see in the clip he's physical
he has great arm length he's very very
fast more shot a lot more actually told
me that Ward is faster than him and
probably a better overall athlete so
that's the type of guy you're getting
and yeah he'll come up with a the wood a
little bit so it's not the conventional
pick we expected with Bradley Chubb but
I think it is a smart move because this
was their biggest need outside of court
if you look at their quarterbacks
Terrence Mitchell EJ Gaines Jamar Taylor
really no 100 but I know that this was
not your number one corner no he was not
he's certainly not listened it's hard to
argue against this guy let me just say
this the film was impressive he's in a
phenomenal man-to-man cover corner he
has got unbelievable just loose fluid
hips and all those things and he ran for
three two but he also chose not to run
the three cone drill in the 20-yard
shuttle and those are the things that I
thought on film were his weakest thing
that's where I would say his ability to
break on the ball be in backpedal break
on seeing the quarterback throwing the
ball I did not think was top-notch
I just don't listen if you have them
there's other corners in this draft that
I think are every bit as good or if not
they're maybe just a hair worse okay so
I wouldn't have done this at number four
that's my issue with Ryan of course
Bradley Chubb was on the board so let me
get the grades where do you go I think
they're gonna be different yeah I went
with a B+ because I do feel like this
was such a big need for them and I like
Denzel Ward a lot but you mentioned if
they're Bradley Chubb was on the board
the idea of pairing him and miles
Garrett is just too good for me to pass
up but Ward is a good player he's a day
1 starter and in that division you need
someone who could cover Antonio Brown
that might be the guy who can do it yeah
maybe so I'm gonna give it a c-minus
just because first of all anything
Denzel Ward's the clear-cut corner best
corner in the drop and yeah this is the
NFL
it's about getting after the quarterback
let's see who's been in the Superbowl
Seattle Seahawks Eagles teams like that
that can get up as a quarterback Broncos
yet Bradley Chubb on the board just
doesn't make sense to me there I will
say this though for mr. Ward grew up in
Ohio yeah birthday is in two days
pretty cool than the awesome - there's a
really good day we're not trying to be
to antagonize Brendan ever drafted Ohio
State guys in the previous regime
regimes so you know they're going wild
up there right now yeah you're running
to the corner Denzel Ward's their guy
that picked for the Browns at number
four okay now it gets crazy well it's
already crazy actually I did not expect
that at number four but you we had her
before that the Broncos like Denzel Ward
so now he's off the board I don't think
they were expecting
Bradley Chubb to be there we know that a
lot of people could trade up and then
also there's all of the quarterbacks
that are still left Rosen is still there
Allen is now still the board at five and
that is perfect for all of our
simulations of the Buffalo Bills trading
up to get Josh Allen possibly at number
five all of these are possibilities
right now it is man I'm getting a chub
it's just a matter of what Denver is
gonna ask for for Buffalo to move up to
slide back to 12 is rich so according to
Ian rapport of NFL Network you said
Buffalo is not willing to give up the
required two first-round pick right now
go for Josh ow yeah that's that's how
they've been saying yeah we eater king
sent his article the only one to get rid
of one because they have a lot of holes
on their offensive line after Eric wood
had to retire Richie incognito retire
than trade up Buffalo make John Elway
pick Josh James Josh Howell might go to
try no we don't know exactly right so
yes
don't there all right so then what what
is your prediction for the Broncos I
think they just take job you think I'm
working on finding out for sure I think
they're gonna go Quinton Nelson if you
miss a Quinton Nelson I mean Chubb would
be so awesome but damn they got
Shaquille Barrett and Shane ray I just I
have a hard time thinking they're the
pick is in though we're getting close
yeah because look I looked ahead Shane
ray and Shaquille Barrett they're both
free agents after the season okay I look
at their safety situation I know they
have Darian Stewart and Justin Simmons
are kind of set their the pick is in do
you know the pick you didn't just Connor
know the pick I do not know the pick
okay
so do you want to steal Connors thunder
again no I don't know it's right no no I
still study right here so we look you
mouth it to him and then he'll say it
yet got it right Connor right
what's the Vic according to me we're
gonna Matt Miller so I didn't set me up
here
the Broncos took Bradley choke Wow
now here's the thing - Sims his point
Sims made a good point that they have
depth at this spot but I believe should
kill Barret hits for agency after this
year Shane right so this is a long-term
pick yeah and he'll have a nice an
impact he's better than both of those
guys and it's not even trouble over
Shane they're Shaquille bad versatility
this feels a lot like the Leonard
Williams chat space it does in your life
without a we I know that deep I know we
have Mohammed Wilkerson and Sheldon
Richardson but how do we pass up Leonard
Williams right
Bradley Chubb yeah we don't need to wait
for Goodell we got a little Shum bunch
of shows the combination punch of it's a
French hat making this s-sure we never
like I wasn't getting tipped like I am
this year I felt like you were actually
sorry for Bradley Chubb I gave it an A+
yeah I'm going there - how can you
double + yeah double bunch of munch um
he'll probably be invited to the Von
Miller passing Academy where he can
learn and remember Von Miller said that
Bradley Chubb in his mind was a
combination of Von Miller and Khalil
Mack and now they're on the same team
man wow that's gonna be pretty awesome
love it it's we're ready to do a video
let's make some magic the rumors were
there for the Broncos for a long time
would they pull the trigger on a
quarterback would it be a corner I don't
think they expected the pass rusher to
be available at NC State Bradley Chubb I
don't think you did either so what kind
of value are they getting the value is
great here's the number two overall
player on my board the top defensive
player and when you can get an elite
pass rusher you get the guy himmat Von
Miller together oh my goodness good luck
Kansas City Chiefs
good luck Oakland Raiders and good luck
LA Chargers right I don't know how you
block those two together chubs gonna
bring a power element to the game I
think he
allows you to be very versatile up front
so yeah the values great I had a super
high gray on this kid
on field all filled it he checks every
box he is a phenomenal football player
he was one of the safest picks in the
whole draft I mean you at the very least
you're gonna be the guy that goes to a
Pro Bowl a few times he just started on
your defense for the next 10 years I
mean he's got it all left go great power
gonna dominate tight ends in the run
game can dominate tackles in the run
game set the edge come off the edge he's
extremely twitchy athlete and as I told
you leading up to this the most
impressive thing is the guy's a hundred
miles per hour on every play and he
plays a lot during the game if he's
Olivier Vernon to me that's what I look
at it's funny the last few years or a
big question to all the pass rushers
were the motor not an issue with him
your grade for getting shove at five-man
this is an A+ I am rough on John Elway a
lot this was the the best pick I've seen
him make as GM of the Denver Broncos
because he didn't get cute he didn't
overthink it he just took the best
player on the board and built a strength
for his defense yeah a plus as well it's
just too much of an important position
this day and age defensive end has
become a passing league we don't know
where the rules are gonna go with the
new contact thing and all that as well I
mean Chubb and von Miller off the edge
that is going to be a handful for every
offensive ball when he was at NC State
his coach decided to give him Mario
Williams number number 9 as a way to
honor how good he is Mario Williams went
1 Chubb slipped to 5 and now he's paired
with Von Miller AFC West Chargers got a
pass rush Broncos got a pass rush good
luck
quarterbacks Chubb is in Denver
I think bunch of I think this is
something we talked about during our
preview show yesterday we talked about
maybe the Oakland Raiders getting Mike
McGlinchey right man he looks pretty
damn important right now
yes I worry about these guys and Justin
Houston and Bosa and Ingram well he they
got great good old Johnny might have
better call across the bay go hey Kyle
you used to work for me doing solid and
don't pick Michael McGlinchey I mean
because that's it he's got to worry
about you don't worry about the team in
his own damn City that might take the
guy he wants all right so the Colts pick
is in apparently Wow
I'm gonna go quit Nelson I don't know if
they need that actually I'm gonna change
it up I'm gonna go I'm going role Kwanza
I'm going Tremayne Edmonds now I'm gonna
go quit Nelson I think you're right that
their offensive line is doubtful they
were in on all these interior offensive
line guys throughout the process with
visits with workouts
I think it's quitting else you're right
it's gonna be quick I talked to Quinton
there you go is it go ahead gives in
alright let's go to Connor
Colts finally get some protection for a
Nelson I'm very excited Quinton Nelson
right now is at his lake house with his
friends and family so shout out to quit
Nelson but I look at their offensive
line and the reason why I think this
makes a lot of sense you look and you go
man Costanza you Hort Ryan Kelly Matt's
loss and Denzel good it's not that bad
right but you look slow some you Horton
good all free agents after this animal
not that good and oh no not not quit
Nelson good no that's the that's the
point plug and play at all-pro all-pro
yeah him and Ryan Kelly next is Ryan
Kelly can get healthy yes those two
together good people forget they tie
know that Alabama is a first-round pick
yes I mean yeah people forget people do
forget shut up all right guys amazing I
got to do NBC Notre Dame stuff I saw him
all year long I got to talk to him see
him in person the attitude the body the
physical skills they're everything you
want out of NFL guard this day and age I
mean this is a guy that when your team
plays the Philadelphia Eagles and they
have Fletcher Cox the Indianapolis Colts
well they'll be able to go
Oh Quinton can handle Fletcher Cox by
himself we don't have to worry about
reorganizing the past protections and
things like
so I have a quote that I can't read it's
not gonna have time in the video this is
a quote from Quinton else about how he
attacks defenders I want to dominate all
my opponents and take their will away to
play the game and finish them past the
witness that's a Jersey Way the Jersey
Way may be out of here when you're doing
the read the Old Spice video and Derwin
James and roll Quan Smith were here yeah
quit and I told you this quittin walked
out of the room and they looked at me
and said he's enormous like I don't even
know what to do when he's coming out
that's quittin Bryson and he's athletic
hey guys guys the quarterbacks they are
all fallen me likey who's gonna scoop oh
I thought for sure at this point like a
few weeks ago I would have gone yes I
probably would have gone man
Baker Mayfield and Lamar Jackson are on
the board and the other three are gone
all right let's get let's make this
video cuz now we need to talk about
trades man the draft is so good isn't it
I'd really attack some games over here
just gloat about the Browns picks or the
new Justin Gilbert and Johnny Manziel
Wow
oh listen I did he's bitter yeah all
right let's do it the Indianapolis Colts
had to go through a year where Andrew
Luck couldn't see the field why because
he gets hit too damn much well guess
what I don't think that's happening
anymore because quittin Nelson the AP
all-american for Notre Dame the first
unanimous all-american since 1993 for
Notre Dame Wow
goes at number six value here he was the
number three player on the board the
best offensive lineman in this draft
class he's a plug-and-play all-pro I
compared him to Steve Hutchinson best
offensive he's tough he's aware his
football IQ is off the charts you'll see
him so many times he comes out of his
stance gets the D tackle out of the way
it's like oh wait let me let me help out
the guys on the right side cuz they suck
I'll pick up the protection for them
great in the run game this is like you
said Andrew Luck has been hit way too
many times is he and Ryan Kelly together
in the middle of that line solved that
problem Sims the Indianapolis Colts last
year last in the NFL and sacks allowed
56 how much does that change with one
guy
I mean yes they were banged up on their
offensive line altogether but this guy's
a once every so often type of talent on
the offensive line at the guard position
we talking like Zack Martin I I actually
think he has a true guard he is better
than Zack Martin was coming out Zach
Bowen was playing left tackle and Notre
Dame has seniors last year there this
guy is a guard and he's a guard all the
way and he's a road grader and he has
zero weakness to his game I saw him in
person at every home Notre Dame game
this year
he's even better in person and oh yeah
the new head coach is Frank Reich he
likes to pull guards he likes to run the
ball so that makes sense cuz he's gonna
kick somebody bigger than Zack Martin
Wow hey this is a giant man he's a shot
he is a bolt just a block he's a block
with legs
sure great man you know this isn't a
plus to get the number three player on
the board and I I do love that the Colts
said we're gonna get Andrew Luck back
hey let's give him some help
let's fix this we can get defense with
all those second-round picks that we
have this is a really really great pick
your speller great you send your papers
back I'm a plus Chris Ballard plus no I
mean it's just smart I mean it's smart
for their team they didn't overthink it
too like Miller says in a lot of it one
of his best phrases yeah they didn't
overthink it's best player on the board
they needed this area to be improved
you've got a lot of money invested in
Andrew Luck and we haven't had a run
game in Indianapolis since I don't know
when it is about time is really the
conclusion they're quitting Nelson the
first pick in the draft for the
Annapolis Colts at number six and they
got themselves a really good one so the
bills are trading those are at bills are
at pick seven no details yet so I will
be shocked if it's not Josh yeah 100%
yeah me too I mean this is the guy from
the start this is New England Brian day
ball this is Sean McDermott who came
from Carolina and saw the biggest
quarterback in the history of the sport
I just have a hard time thinking in
Buffalo that they wouldn't want a guy
who's thrown in Buffalo type weather in
Wyoming and I'll tell you what man it's
it's cool that they didn't have to trade
up to five where it seemed like they had
to they were able to wait and these
quarterbacks now they only had to give
up two second-round picks
about twelve and twelve and two second
rounds so when you look at the bills
draft stock they actually had some of
the most picks available in the draft
they had nine picks total five in the
first three rounds they had twelve 22
and then in the second round they're the
21st pick and the 24th pick so they're
gonna be able to keep their 22nd pick so
if you're the bills here think about
this the bills could trade up take their
quarterback and Josh Allen and then
maybe get like a will Hernandez at 22 to
protect that core I agree there's gonna
be some offensive linemen there that yes
we will make sense a 20 right exactly
right so the bills did not have to go
all the way up but Josh Allen with lake
effect if it is Josh shallow woods for
me it would be an A and one thing that
everyone knows this is not a secret that
Allen and I have a relation of
friendship
dating you know back over a year he
always thought muscle would be the
team's gonna come get him that's
interest I don't know anything I don't
even what why ever might I do know now
just like good oh now you're sure it's
awesome yeah big is then yeah yeah
Connor Connor its bills a good
quarterback and it's the biggest
no-brainer ever they didn't have to go
up to number two and that's what they
wanted to go up to number two for this
guy Josh Allen yeah Josh there boy now
the other works I about this now the
12th pick they got in the Cordy Glen
trade right and that's why you know you
have to trade protection to eventually
get your quarterback which is
interesting what were your grades a plus
a plus Wow hey Connor stick to football
bet update I keep my hair and mellow how
skinny and your brothers getting a
tattoo we had a bet back in November
that if Josh Allen was a top 10 pick or
not right brother who's the co-host
right nice to get a chance to get a
natty light [ __ ] stamp
because josh Allen with top ten that's
our serious yeah it's horrible
sorry Mel oh damn oh I had to get a
Boulevard tattoo if he didn't go too
crazy okay getting nervous darn to sweat
I was getting nervous
all right so and you know what so I look
at the Bucks we're they in a position so
they go back five to twelve maybe they
can get a Derwin
at well they probably go Derwin or Minko
will be there we like both will go back
that's what I would think that was the
first thing that went through my head
and then the Bucks also get two more
picks just good draft capital yes-man
all right you guys let me know we're
ready to make a video we'll make some
magic because when you look that means
now that the Bucks have three picks in
the second round all of the six pick and
the other one either offensive line in
the second round that's what they're
gonna do cuz they didn't have a third so
now they get three picks in that range
yeah great yep
Wow love it okay in every single mock
draft the bills were trading up but it
was usually two five they trade up to
seven and they get their quarterback the
big man with a powerful arm to handle
the wind jaw sound out of Wyoming yeah
you think no I love the value here he
was my number two quarterback in this
draft just a shade behind Sam darn 'old
we've talked for a year about the
athletic traits I was actually at that
game he has the best arm I've ever seen
and he doesn't miss plays incredible yes
yeah this play we were saving the press
box screaming which you're not supposed
to do though he every 65 to 45 I
compared him to Cam Newton because yes
the accuracy needs work you see it 56%
it's gonna get mentioned over and over
again but the arm and Chris says it all
the time sizes a trait he has great size
very good athlete and he's only getting
better one year JUCO tears at Wyoming
you can't tell me this kids been coached
agree right I think he's only gonna get
better yeah I'm with you all the way my
favorite quarterback on the draft left
go I mean I think this is the perfect
guy for the bills the bills I got Brian
day balls their new offensive
coordinator where's he from New England
they want big pocket passing type
quarterbacks not only is this guy big
Miller I will second you you're right I
mean I didn't think I'd be saying this
the year after passion for my homes but
it's the strongest arm I've ever seen I
mean that's what kind of thrower he is
and he is an elite athlete this is the
second best athlete at the quarterback
position in the draft behind Lamar
Jackson so to me it's awesome for them
and it's even better that they didn't
have to leverage the farm to go up and
get them it's been pretty cool to see
the bills they clear house last year and
now they're ready to start oh and by the
way they went to the playoffs yes while
they clean house what is your grade for
Josh Allen factoring in the trade up to
seven giving away to suddenly giving up
two seconds I think that's a big
buenas he huge went for them I gave it
an A+ everyone knows I like Josh Allen
I've liked the kid since last year he
would have been my top quarterback over
Mitch Travis key in the 2017 draft I
like that they did this I wouldn't be
shocked if they find a way to get him on
the field right away I agreed yes
because what's gonna happen I'm giving
an A+ so we can get there but what's
gonna really happen is people on the
Buffalo Bills team are gonna see him on
the field next to AJ McCarron he's gonna
throw 10 footballs and they're gonna go
oh my gosh this guy is special and it's
gonna change everything up there for
Buffalo but great pic for them they got
their new Jim Kelly man going forward
very good pretty incredible
Josh Allen grew up on a small grain and
cotton farm and in some scouting
services was a zero star athlete Wow now
the zero started now he's a seventh pick
in the draft in the future of the
Buffalo Bills so Josh Allen goes seven
now we're sitting here with Chicago on
the clock at 8:00 yeah well anyone come
up for Josh right yeah I just got the
Cardinals I got a text people we're
trying and the bear said no okay so
they'd like someone here a lot I did
yesterday on a Dickey show man that like
McGlinchey and Harry high said our best
friends hey Harry hi stay just for
everyone that doesn't know was the
offensive line coach for Notre Dame he
is now the offensive line coach I
believe for the Bears yes and he loves
McGlinchey that's a possibility I don't
know maybe linebacker the picks not eat
up linebacker certainly can be applied
there they need linebackers trained
Edmonds is definitely on the board I'm
gonna go Jermaine Edmonds that's who I
would pick if I were them I would go
with Jermaine Edmonds he yelled and
Smith for Vic Fangio I mean not even
Alden Smith I think he's more of like he
first of all this guy's an animal in
which we've never really seen before so
he's almost like a yeah he's an anthony
bar for Vic Fangio okay guy a Brian
Urlacher best McGlinchey here you think
it's gonna be gotta go with ya it's too
obvious or anything it's just enough
right ya know and when I told you that
before the USC game I'm on the field for
NBC and the Bears scouting staff was
there to look at Notre Dame's offensive
line we were all wrong we're all wrong
that's Rwanda one sec he's more pad
Willa's honor you want to make the pick
for us no leak yet Oh
Miller's a head Miller has it Miller
your shoes sorry
I'll shotgun an a-t-m first person the
pic is in its rope one Wow
what we knew I was gonna curse
eventually all right so what's
interesting to me here now is we still
have Josh Rosen on I wanted to be
Jermaine ro Kwan like I just it makes
sense a he's more like Patrick Willis I
can see that like for Vic Fangio it
makes a lot of yes yeah when you look at
the the Bears defense it's funny man the
Bears defense was seventh in against the
past eleventh against the rush but right
there in the middle of their linebacker
there's an open spot next to Danny
Trevathan it was Nick quiet Kowski he
did a linebacker and I would say
tremaine's him has a huge ceiling
I think roll Quan is more solid yes I
would say that too as well yes it
remains a little bit more of our
projection like I said I think the one
thing that defensive coordinators were
looking at Jermaine Edmunds is my little
one weakness with him just that he's not
always gonna just throw his body around
with reckless abandon what are your
grades for roll quad
I gave it a B+ yeah I'm gonna give it an
A - and now the actually I'm just gonna
give it an a corner true a really yeah
now though the future Super Bowl
champions the fighting [ __ ] Shanahan all
right Rock Juan Smith man from Montezuma
George a Mason County all the way want
to give a quick shout out Felder and
Nelson we love you we miss you I hope
you guys are watching you guys are the
best all their shows watches broke Juan
Smith very interesting note from shefter
yeah chapter says that the bills and the
Broncos had a trade mapped out and the
Broncos when Bradley Chubb fell to them
said no way we're moving wow so they
waited and then it didn't matter because
then the bills only had to give up
that's why you wait they're still coming
up for Josh out yeah almost a right so
but the rule goes when they saw Bradley
Chubb they said negative ghostrider
we're staying fat right watch Green Bay
here at nine
yeah you think this is where they can
make a move that's what you were hearing
before and you think it's what to make a
corner for Minka I think our Minka oh
that's right all right whenever you guys
are ready we'll be ro Quan
in this draft there were certain
blue-chip prospects that you just knew
what they were gonna be in the NFL and
the Chicago Bears they sat there at 8:00
and they got one in linebacker row kwan
smith out of Georgia the kid flies the
kid flies wasn't my number 10 player in
this draft one of the best linebackers
one of the best defenders he won the
Bronco Nagurski last year and you watch
him play shrew Mike linebacker he can
get outside the hashes he can pull the
chain a little bit and get after the
quarterback but I love the his motor the
tenacity that he plays with and he's
more of this new-age linebacker where in
Vick Fangio's defense he's probably
gonna see hey I had a couple guys like
this before and I know exactly how he's
gonna slide in
I like Tremaine Edmunds better Rokon
Smith there's no doubt he's a very good
prospect what does he remind you of yeah
I mean he's a little Patrick Willis ish
that's why I'm kind of mad at myself
that I didn't call this out earlier but
I mean this guy's a special guy he
really is roll quants he's one of the
safest picks in the draft there's no
doubt about that I mean the only thing I
could say that it was a negative about
him is that he can play small at times
when guards get on him he wasn't the
greatest of getting off blocks but you
want to talk about downhill Smasher an
impressive explosive lower body and a
guy that's just willing to he doesn't
care he's gonna knock your head off if
you're there to be had so I really like
him it fits the Vic Fangio scheme he is
one little discrepancy I don't like him
pass coverage I think he's a little
tight but they don't ask a lot of past
coverage with their linebacker and the
Vic Fangio defense so it's not gonna be
as bad right go right so that up great I
gave it a B+ I did like Tremaine Edmunds
a little bit better but I think ro Quon
comes right in we talked about it he
fills a need for them in this front
seven with Hakeem Hicks Leonard Boyd it
started was pretty good I think he
slides right into a huge role for them
unheard for yeah Georgia can yeah yes
right I mean they were unreal I'm gonna
be in a row kwan smith he was one of the
10 best players in the draft for me is a
phenomenal football player fits the
scheme explosive gonna bring attitude to
this defense and miller you're right I
mean in this debt modern-day NFL even
too with the screens the horizontal game
you need a guy that can turn run and go
run down receivers or tight ends or
whoever it may be when Matt Nagy got the
head coaching job for the Chicago Bears
when the first phone calls he made Vic
Fangio I need you to stay
ngo has his middle linebacker in Rwanda
they got him at number 8 for the Bears
okay so we clear fire here so don't be
afraid to tell me I supporters are gonna
pick Miller's gonna have some news and
then Sims is going to call Kyle Shanahan
live after the selection but it could be
a try it could be the end of our
friendship yeah I've heard the Bucs are
trying to trade up as well to get Darwin
James oh they were trying to trade up
they're trying to come over they're
trying to come back up now holy cow so
they go they get to and they they like
trade one I love them josh is having fun
that's laughs you're a Bears fan take me
through what you want here I want to
trade you want to trade I want to trade
I would love to remain Edmonds here and
I've said all along that the end the
pick is in so I I would love Tremayne
Edmonds I we talked about it in the
preview show I would not be surprised if
it's Mike neva I know I'm going
McGlinchey to what I don't ask Kyle
these kind of things cuz I don't want to
know the answers cuz if I'm right then I
can't say it so but I would think
McGlinchey to the way he talked to me I
know Tremaine Edna's in conversation
there was a lot of rumors today about
possibly trading Trenton Brown right and
I know it I don't know if that's gonna
happen or not and we talked about Joe
Staley will be a free agent soon as I
think we were all right yesterday
leaning toward McGlinchey because of yes
like you and I talked about today again
Meiko different brand might get traded
yes and if the Niners and I guess they
are keeping the pick McGlinchey makes
the most sense I am gonna be
disappointed that it's not germane
Edmunds
alright the pick we're talking my ear I
get was hard to focus Niners Niners took
McGlinchey good that's the right pick it
is well especially when you just paid in
your words a zillion dollars for Jimmy
Garoppolo right yes you did that and you
blew I don't want to say you blew but
you have a first-round pick from last
year that's a little questionable right
now this guy's safe I mean yes I mean
it's just he makes too much sense yeah
not sexy but man he's good I know that I
know that but look she's definitely be
down on your board though I know he was
number 22 my board I just I thought he
was a right tackle but guess what he's
gonna play right tackle yeah and this
happens every trip yes sir
position to get overdraft and we go oh
yeah that makes sense I'm just glad we
figured it earlier this week but Glynn
she could be drafted this yeah tackles
are gonna get over browser just sitting
there getting the camera on its hackles
are gonna get over drafted when they're
really good it's a too too important of
a position I mean damn you know like a
person for him was Jack Conklin if he
can just come in here yeah super salt in
their own game and one thing that oh
yeah what are your grades I already gave
mine mine would be plus I'm gonna get
I'm gonna give it an a Connor no I said
am i bad I'm an idiot I saw both A's do
you know who his first cousin is Michael
McGlinn cheese first Ryan yeah I covered
Notre Dame this year you can forgetting
that I'm the one that told you about
dick hammer
look I'm like McGlinchey good chin on
that guy oh this guy so this is like
face of the franchise left this is
Captain America right here I'm telling
you play left yeah I do think eventually
he implies games yeah I think I really
high all scheme one of them I'd I think
in three years from now when he's a few
pounds heavier and a bigger man his only
issue is maybe anchor to a degree but
it's not troubling I mean he played some
big-time pass rushers last year's pretty
incredible men pick six picked nine both
Notre Dame offensive line right I I mean
yeah I mean you you remember last year
when I I first watched them on film
getting ready for against really good
and I was like oh my gosh I mean this is
the best left side of the left line and
the left side of the line in college
football yeah and some people are like
what's better than Alabama and I was
like I don't know but this number 56
kids going in the top 10 and the other
guy I thought was gonna go like in the
20s
let's do Mike McGlinchey to the Niners
at pic number 9 for our favorite coach
in I tell Shannon Dyle Shannon and you
have to call him up as soon as we get to
the of it and then our friendship will
be over it's worth it in a beautiful
trade John Lynch was able to secure
Jimmy Garoppolo
and now he's securing Jimmy Garoppolo
yet again with the ninth pick in the
draft Mike McGlinchey that tackle out of
Notre Dame what do you think of this
pick mister Niner yeah as a Niners fan I
like the pig because yeah we're gonna
protect Jimmy Garoppolo and I think he's
a great scheme fit in this zone scheme
I was not super high on him as a left
tackle but guess so he's gonna play
right tackle and in two years from Joe
Staley retires
maybe you can slide him over so the
value I had a first-round grade on him
but I did him have him at 22 overall I
think you can watch the Georgia tape the
Miami tip that we're seeing right there
there were some deficiencies against
speed but put him at right tackle he
could be a Jack Conklin like player
right away Sims you know Kyle Shannon's
offense this is a lineman that fits his
scheme without question he does and I
just look at the right tackle they have
on the roster right now at Trent Brown
he's a huge man that's just not what
Kyle Shanahan's had in his past he likes
athletic offensive linemen McGlinchey is
extremely athletic you see the length I
do think like Miller is saying in two
years from now when Joe Staley moves on
or retires he will be your franchise
left tackle for the 10 years after that
but man the thing that's so impressive
to me and I know why my buddy Kyle
Shanahan like them it's because the runn
blocking is off the charts I covered
them all year I saw him in person when I
turned on the film I was still blown
away by it so they just Garoppolo this
is Jarek McKidd my gosh yes he is gonna
go back it's gonna help their whole
offense what is your grade I gave it an
A I love the idea that hey let's go
protect Jimmy Garoppolo let's help the
run game I think it makes everyone
better they've loaded up with Western
Rick Berger free agent yes they interior
line play was bad last year think
McGlinchey and Joe Staley can help make
everything a little bit easier on the
inside so it's an A for this Niners fan
I'm going to a as well yes I think this
guy is a phenomenal football player
that's gonna put your franchise in a
great position for a long time he's
gonna help guard I mean help protect
Jimmy Garoppolo who they've invested a
ton of money into and he just fits what
they want to do scheme wise if the
athleticism at that positions tackle man
in the NFL I mean the 49ers got to play
the Broncos this year they got Von
Miller and Bradley Chubb going up so
it's kind of important number 9 yes the
Niners go Mike McGlinchey offensive
tackle out of
okay we got a trade okay what the
Cardinals have traded to pick number 10
I'm praying it's a no-brainer Rosa you
had to get on Alami yes no no I want
LaMarcus I want my bold prediction be
right Bruce Arians once I'm gonna take a
little R he doesn't work there anymore
so no no I loved that became a storyline
your old coach wants your team to take a
player okay I go to get your health
drafts easy a legitimate question if yes
Rosen first Simms and Miller yeah is
this a bad landing spot because of how
much how poor the offensive line is
right now for a guy with concussions
what did I argue before the drafts this
will be a place that would scare me
because he's he's not gonna be able to
physically carry the team now I did go
out and they did sign Justin Puetz oh
they have a cue Shipley are you potty DJ
home yes good player that's why they're
available just a 40,000,000 not I can't
talk about I love the guy yeah he's
worth it he was an improvement to their
offensive line and he's got positional
versatility because 100% Josh Rosen
ninety-nine point nine okay I'm gonna go
with that point one I'm going Lamar
Jackson's actually Oh point zero one man
what roll room yelling at you why would
they trade up for Lamar Jackson because
they wouldn't I got these I got the very
valid point from the control room wow
that's
I do like Rosen in this market because
that is something that we've talked a
lot about if if he went to New York yeah
there's a spotlight they didn't give up
much to go from 15 to tell what are you
hearing that from 15 to 10 it costs them
obviously flip of the picks picks 79 and
baked 152 yeah and here's the thing too
is the Cardinals had to third-round
picks so they trade one they still now
have a second and third-round pick they
were gonna come out so what is the
greater is gonna do yeah they're Raiders
I would like Rosen better with the
Dolphins I do Marcus Davenport or
something like that makes a lot of sense
or yeah that's a good question woody
where's woody my forehead shiny I need
some powder on my face I mean that one
but but Josh Rosen
oh all right so there is the official
one it's a 15 like a third and the fifth
to move up five spots it's not a lot
it's not bad at all
in terms of Arizona Mike McCoy's offense
how does Josh Rosen fit into that I mean
it's Mike McCoy's offense just think
about Jake Delhomme back in the day with
the Carolina Panthers something similar
along those range yes he's gonna fit
that totally it's a pro-style offense
it's almost a little New England Bill
Parcells when I got a lot of them right
they want to run the ball they're gonna
drop back and pass the ball they're
gonna look to throw the ball kind of
aggressively down the field
what do you come on in here by the way I
need a sure what is your grain if it's
Josh Rosen that's an a it's gonna be an
a-plus for me yes I mean Jeff Rosen was
my second favorite quarterback in the
draft I mean yes for me he is one of the
safest picks at the position in the
draft I'll say this with Sam Bradford
and whatever other awful quarterback
they have in Bradford and Mike lemon
yeah Rosen should start week one they
got the all frail quarterback squad I
mean nobody's got a lot of muscle or
thickness all right I got the pace thing
all right let's go to Conner no-brainer
it's Josh rose ah crap Rosen it's great
for hours on the tooth that's close to
Southern California it's gonna bring
some of that fan base into the
conversation him being from there I mean
up clean about uni ooh yeah yes an
underrated thing that you have to think
about one project Oh when I got drafted
by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I was like
what
all right so hold I have my random fact
that I'm not gonna get into the video
that's great I gotta wear that yeah what
was your grade Sims was an A+ was your
grade Miller let's make it an A+ A+
Connor
Josh Rosen's father yes was a national
gold medalist in i'ts in ice dancing and
became an orthopedic surgeon and was
once on President Obama's shortlist to
become the US Surgeon General Wow and
Josh Rosen was a tennis prodigy right
which is my favorite part about Josh
right right I love Joshua no so he's not
going to Mary Hill but you know we're
Jews going to get older Florida you do
both okay he's definitely gonna limit
scoffs real estate okay
all right there is a give the hug he's
given the hug left go did you tell him
to give him a hug yeah he went a little
broad there was a little like talking
and mouth oh yeah that was a four
quarterbacks neck top ten man yep
did you have any bet on that ain't
anymore natty one ready to go yeah I
want on my bed yeah I'm set you lost
your Donald Arizona jumps up Josh Rosen
falls down it could be a match made in
heaven Carson Palmer just four tires I
know they got Sam Bradford but guess
what it's the second time that Sam
Bradford got a big contract and a rookie
quarterback came in
Carson Wentz now Josh Rosen what do you
think about Rosen at Ten yeah it's a
great value I had him as the number
three quarterback in this class number
eight player overall like you said they
have Sam Bradford so they had to trade
up to get Josh Rosen and not give up
much to do it
prettiest thrower in the draft the
mechanics are on point she's no matter
if canny stay healthy he's had
concussions he said shoulder injuries
he's not the biggest guy I think he's a
better athlete than he was getting
credit for but he's gonna be on high
alert behind that offensive line I do
think he was the most Pro ready
quarterback in this class and someone
who can come in and play week one if
they need him to and I think they do
need him too because what they have is
not good yeah it's really gonna be just
about whether they feel comfortable out
the offensive line in front of him do
they want him did go out there right
away and have to deal with that but let
go you know my thoughts on this guy Josh
Rosen he was the most game ready ready
to go day one NFL quarterback out of all
these guys he is a unbelievable thrower
the football I mean he really is it is
consistent it's extremely accurate he's
a great decision-maker
he's got great field within the pocket
as well and he has a stronger arm than I
think people gave him credit for that
would be one thing I would argue as well
the injury thing it is real certainly
but man just as far as a pure precision
pocket quarterback yet this is I look at
him and I said this is Matt Ryan mate
with a better arm but a hair less
athletic Taylor what's your grade I give
it an A+ am i player compared front for
comparison for him was Jared Goff
so if you can keep him healthy you can
get that type of quarterback so I think
it's a great trade and a great pick a
plus I mean you're getting
what I think is the second best
quarterback in the draft at what does
this pick number 10 they traded up to so
phenomenal for them and they got the
quarterback of the future of their
franchise it's Arizona it's a
small-market team he's from down the
road in Southern California it all makes
sense it's a good pick by that and it
only took them to move up to five spots
a third and a fifth pass a base yeah to
get the quarterback of the future Josh
the Rosen one was in Arizona